comcast Anastasia they vow to love you
faithfully wedding-vow narration
exposition bow nearest position all that
I have is now yours he's still giving
the main vows not the ring centric vows
but the footage is over the ring because
this movie understands dick all about
actual matrimony and knows everything
about pseudo salacious sex you may kiss
the bride
no we use that 17 inch dildo that's
currently in your jacket pocket I don't
really care the vows are over and I'm
headed to the reception to get a
highball is it just me or all these
wedding guests flashing the help I'm
under duress signal
you know if they made about six more of
these movies I bet it would be possible
to squeeze five total seconds of
believable chemistry out of these two
leads the director and the set decorator
had a huge fight over how many testicle
shaped chandeliers were needed for this
wedding
obviously the set decorator run because
he has an affiliate marketing
relationship with Jolie in a display of
solidarity with the couple grandma
agreed to get flogged while wearing a
ball gag later tonight weirdly enough
the ball gag was on the registry let's
get out there I'm sick of sharing you at
the referral that's racist
also Anna then completely changed out of
her dress into an off-white pant suit
while Christian unbuttoned his top
button and took off his bow tie you own
this we own this Scott damn movie she
already knows he's rich enough to have
private planes and they're already
married enough to know they share
possessions so this cheap-ass line that
sets up a cheap-ass response is
everything wrong with the dialogue in
this series and I'm just gonna go ahead
and assign at 15 sins carrying her over
the threshold of your honeymoon hotel
room romantic carrying her across the
threshold of your fancy private jet that
will fear you to to the honeymoon
elitist as hell yo Christian check your
priveledge ah Rosie the perfect wine for
people who don't have the balls to favor
Ritter White we're nearly four minutes
into this thing and still getting
on-screen text credits Jesus
well the soundtracks mostly mediocre pop
songs that you'd hear in the background
at Target but we paid Danny three
million just out of habit this Parisian
honeymoon montage is so vanilla that it
could easily be from any Matthew
McConaughey Kate Hudson movie from the
mid-2000s is this what Fifty Shades fans
tune in for there was like two seconds
of obscure missionary sex directed by
James Foley a guy you get to direct
everyone else has turned down such as
this movie you're watching right now the
previous movie in this franchise about
the corruptor a chow yun-fat joint and
the chamber the least remembered film
based on a John Grisham novel in the
history of ever you wanna be ogle by
every guy in the beach
including tailor this guy with the
whipping and the historical bondage
dares to play the jealousy card like
this film could be shown as is the law
enforcement personnel as a textbook case
of what an abusive relationship looks
like but it keeps thinking it's sexy I
see someone saw sneakers
god damn it is it now mandated for every
movie server room to be blue
there's nothing but boobs for as far as
the eye can see nobody cares about mine
they will when they're on the cover some
sleazy tabloid what about the cover of a
non sleazy or less sleazy tabloid like
People magazine do they still make
people magazine
Life magazine the irony here is that no
matter which magazine I choose this joke
will inevitably end up outdated say what
you will about these movies being sex
fantasies for the middle-class women of
America and they are these movies are
just as much lifestyle fantasies for
middle-class women of America you insist
on defying me mrs. gray what should I do
about that I'm guessing the same you've
been doing the last two movies only this
time you'll get bombed or hacked or hack
bond at some point Dakota Johnson got
through this movie with one simple
mantra Sharon Stone eventually got
nominated for an Oscar Sharon Stone
eventually got nominated for an Oscar
you know I'm hetero and married but even
I'd like to see Christians to at this
point if only for some variety
I should more often why outside of the
useless handcuffs that was extremely
tame sex like haven't they been peeing
this entire honeymoon
god damn I hate this dialogue I'm sorry
but for some reason I used FaceTime
instead of the regular phone in the
hopes that I'd catch a glimpse of your
super boring missionary humping we'd
have fire in the main server room this
morning was anyone injured see he likes
to cause pain to women that looked like
his mom because it helps him shoot his
semen everywhere but he's a good guy
because his first question after
learning about the fire was regarding
his employees well-being also maximize
that window there's no reason to keep
this video chat window minimized unless
you think I need visual evidence that
this asshat has a desktop image that is
literally his own company's logo can you
go back
damn Roz and ask you to rewind the
footage not to throw in a zoom an
enhance cliche they said it looks like
sabotage sabotage why wouldn't you tell
me that I don't want you to worry
here's another movie character keeping
information from a loved one that most
people would totally tell their loved
ones out of some screenwriters
manufactured need to avoid worrying said
loved ones Jesus if someone's trying to
kill you then someone's trying to kill
her and you're a great aid bitch if you
hide that information from her can't you
just call me Anna
boom mr. gray likes to be called mr.
gray so that would be a little odd what
does Ana really have so little clout in
this Marik's that she can't have the
staff calling her by whatever name she
chooses doesn't choke yes well moving if
you're gonna start explaining your
narrative intentions I'm gonna need you
to also say things like that was a drama
and that was a sexy do you not wanna
have kids I don't even care that some
couples wait until after they get
married to have this discussion the fact
that she brings this up now is some both
people they're really checking our to
have more of this I'm not ready to share
you final film in trilogy doubles down
on the possessive and abusive nature if
it's male lead because I guess it's too
late to turn back
women like abusive men I'm legit
confused as to what conclusions to draw
here hey I can play that too and a
Hannibal Bama banana fanna fo fanna can
we find a spot for him man candy sure
but that's pretty sexist and I'm not
sure this movie about a male dominating
a female that shows lots of lady nudity
but almost zero male nudity is ready for
something like man candy do you mind I
need a word with mr. haire owner of the
company and three-day-old husband barges
into meeting at his wife's office on her
first day back and this is normal this
is not only normal it's romantic and I
beat off to it with my general parts
would you change your name for me yes
I've met that much to you no one will be
seated during the entire third movie
where they argue about marriage every
real-life married couple works out long
before actually getting married I'm
becoming convinced there's more product
placement in the sex movie then there is
sex let me show you what I have in mind
and let me do it in a dimly lit room
where you won't be able to see a
state-of-the-art self-sufficient smart
house self-sufficient so the house is
capable of providing for its own food
and other needs without outside help
I'll just don't eat and they don't have
needs so every house is self-sufficient
I'm guessing you either met a house
where you can live self-sufficiently
meaning one with lots of green space or
some or maybe I meant self-sustaining in
that it produces as much energy as it
consumes which even that would be a
questionable claim any one conduct
business in this town without overt
flirtation like is it a requirement to
be a knowingly pervy to work an upper
echelon CL
please stop speaking of my husband as if
I weren't here or you can go and climb
back into your color car and drive back
to Seattle was that Jia girl out of line
a bit by touching Christians wrist
probably did she really do anything
wrong enough to warrant a response from
Ana that was this over-the-top no
I have removed 100 sins if she'd
woefully underestimated the cars
zero-to-sixty capabilities and driven
this thing toppling end-over-end into
the woods across the street like those
asshats and YouTube videos crashing
Lambos they can't hit close them and
instead of instantly losing this can use
Dodge King Durango the Audi r8 will only
slowly lose him the r8 averages near 600
horsepower whereas the Dodge Durango is
a Dodge Durango go go on in Fifty Shades
also has anyone even thought about
calling the cops come on did I'm
wondering if this is the lowest stakes
car chase in movie history
it's at least tied with Mitchell right
plus your lights that's a dick
this works if anything the drivers less
likely to move out of your fucking way
after exiting the freeway and losing the
tail this movie decides to give you
eight cuts in ten seconds of her driving
through the city this is worse than Liam
Neeson going over the fence and taking
three man I gotta get randomly followed
by a potentially deadly stalker leading
to a moderate speed chase more often
sorry mr. gray we lost him
wait well huh you were in the middle of
downtown traffic it's not like Liz was
in a supercar like Anna it was a janky
ass Dodge you had one job
I want everything there is to know about
height god damnit shouldn't they already
be doing this this is the most
incompetent security detail since paul
blart you know I can't go to New York I
have to work take her with you so he's
going to New York and tries to force her
to go with him but she stays behind
because she doesn't want to be told what
to do and I had to Google to make sure
because I was going insane but yeah
basically all the same happened in the
last move I will be safe I have Sawyer
and Prescott who just showed how great
they are by letting us be followed and
losing the fucking follower this movie
thinks every single thing in the world
is sexy and movie is wrong done
shadowing literally it's even in the
shadows she was promoted to I believe
senior fiction editor not marketing
director why is he looking to cover art
mock-ups she should be reading
manuscripts and then reading more
manuscripts but I guess that's not
visually cool enough why do you look at
me like you know I'm talking about
I don't somehow the discussion in the
writers room made it into the script I
promised Christian don't go home come on
you afraid that your hot bodyguards
gonna narc on you and it was literally
driving the car when someone tried to
chase them down a couple days ago does
she not actually value her own safety
why does perplexing Christian with my
actions seem so frequently to trump
making smart decisions he's working on
this an ego project with that architect
gia Matteo when with really big plans
so what's movie going for here a little
bit of subverted ranch humor clever
dialogue because it fails on all
accounts
you're so married I know honestly it
happened so fast but it happened over
the course of two movies in like six
hours of unrated runtime let me tell him
that I was out with Kate mr. gray
already knows her face suggests that
she's surprised to learn this but
honestly after everything why doesn't
she assume Christian is watching her on
live 4k 360 video at all times the
original title of this movie was Fifty
Shades even dare care
third Twilight bonded ripoff film is
literally a rejected criminal mind spec
script stretched out of it better
Australia holy these security guards
just keep topping their penis all so
they can set up a stupid line about Anna
having handcuffs you owe me a life the
most hilarious aspect of these Fifty
Shades movies is how totally all over
the place they are it's like a al James
sat around and said you know what the
sex story about marriage and bondage and
freedom and car chases and stalkers
needs a dramatic orphaned backstory
dourly day-drinking gank doers one of
the biggest sins in this entire movie is
the color of these sheets
it's like puke and bile got together and
had a baby and then that baby puked up a
raw stomach acid maybe later this makes
no fucking sense Christian's mad at Ana
for going up but she was attacked at
home if anything she survived the attack
because she disobeyed Christian Jesus
even figuring out the logistical flaws
in this movie makes me feel like I need
a shot a bath I don't think I want to
live in a world where showers are no
longer enclosed by walls or glass on all
four sides I guess Christians happy
trail is closed due to flooding also
seriously man for a long-ass time the
sex movie actually refuses to sex he was
it is but you should know by now that
anger only strengthens the power of
Christians boner skin I have no idea why
he's going to these lengths to get to us
there's got to be some connection yeah
let's get our crack team of
investigators on it wait they've been on
it this entire movie this movie about
two people figuring out how to love each
other while simultaneously getting each
other up does not have time for side
plots involving bodyguards in the
literary assistant goddammit the word
hormones should have gotten a co-writing
credit on these books and movies but not
to that enormous house that I just
bought you and will never be featured in
this movie again Rita Ora continues to
be in these movies
[Music]
with a guy like Christian Grey you'd
think the phrase tickling the ivories
would mean something much more sinister
than piano playing but you'd be wrong do
you think Elliot whatever don't you hmm
that depends do you think this tub which
allows both of us to behave as though we
are in separate tubs is long enough anis
nightmares involve her walking down a
gold-plated palace hallway and life
doesn't get more first world problem II
than this we need a fridge that says I'm
rich and I have a small dick how about
one five times the size of a traditional
hall closet
brilliant there you are looking for you
in the fridge even Kim Basinger who's in
the Unrated cut of the movie thinks this
is a discount nine and a half weeks it's
my time man I never thought I'd say a
sex scene involving two attractive
people went on far too long before I
watch this movie love there good luck to
the bear it's finally about to get you
I'm sorry
Dakota Johnson is hottest but this dress
isn't working on her besides not a real
dress sir else it's a dress made for
Olivia Wilde and no one else regardless
it's not working here no matter how
enthusiastic Rita Ora is protagonists
witnesses potential infidelity due to
incredibly convenient appearance of the
cheating spouse cliche I I never asked
Wow I'm actually rooting for Jack to
escape prison and abduct some fools just
so something can happen in this movie
and then I met Kate okay giving a big
speech to a group of friends before
proposing is awkward and horrible enough
but doing it in a nightclub where in
real life no one will be able to hear
you even worse double foul strike two
two strikes in one engagement happiness
for the cup brother yay he deserves to
be happy I think I honestly don't know
and don't care and I'm pretty sure no
one does when Mary's the first girl I
ever dated I'm sure there are some
private jets out there that are quiet
this motherfucker is completely silent
I'm sure it's out of respect for this
brilliant dialogue no way your talk will
be proved the doubters wrong and shows
that a film featuring a variety of butt
plugs can make over 370 million dollars
worldwide it's not a fifty Shades movie
with on a kinky sex montage Jack
attacked me
do you believe what'd he say officially
mrs. gray it doesn't matter what I
believe he's a goddamn detective he
submits testimony that states exactly
what he believes also how was Jack's
attack even slightly in doubt he had a
knife with him right and that was
recovered at the scene did I think he
was using it to car
fine camembert that he picked up on the
way so by showing up at his bail hearing
she guaranteed that he would hate her
more she didn't testify she could easily
have found out his bail sentence from
someone else mere seconds after it was
announced but somehow she convinced
herself she just had to be there in
person when Hines bail was decided I
mean what that is the least sense any
movie that makes no sense ever mate
we're just there
Anastasia couldn't see that she's
hilariously legally blind let's all
laugh about her poor eyesight ha ha
apparently Hyde is trying to say that I
came on to him you expect people to
believe that it's his word against mine
but no it's Anna's word against a slew
of evidence and a clear
breaking-and-entering charge including
assault with a deadly weapon
at this point the movies throwing
everything it can at the wall to see
which plot thread can be the most boring
I'm not ready to figure it out
ladies and gentlemen acting also I'm
just gonna throw 50 sins at Christian
here for being a predictable tool about
a pregnancy he helped cost but decides
to immediately blame the woman for
things up if this movie were made 12
years earlier Evanescence would have had
a lot longer of a career at least two
albums worth of hits guess who's gonna
get the butt plug tonight we're leaving
for work in 20 minutes where the hell
were you this movie is really just a
study of who can be more indignant just
a reality check to anyone actually
finding themselves emotionally invested
here this is their closet it's a
dressing room it holds all their clothes
and accessories and still has 500 square
feet to spare for just walking space
bitch you chose her over me
ah see even the Fifty Shades expanded
universe is an immune to a stupid
protagonist fight before the climax of
the movie cliche it's what your mother
should have done for you and I am so
sorry that she didn't mommy shaming
babies happen when you have sex and you
and I tend to do a lot of that indeed
yet even Ross on friends was shocked to
learn that condoms only work about 97%
of the time and most birth control is
some measure of fallible so we can
either do this together
I wonder if Jamie Dornan actually had
dialogue here but the director just told
him oh maybe just try acting with your
face Hey
and Emma if we can just make the font
size two points bigger copy Olli making
the font size two points bigger on a
book at the last minute is a huge deal
and would never happen unless the scene
were being written by someone with no
knowledge or interest in real publishing
details your husband calls
remind you that he is flying down to
Portland jeez I hope he's not flying his
personal helicopter or we're headed for
another bull fake death ending hmm hmm
if Anna's had her cell phone with her
this whole time
how has Kate not been able to reach her
was she waiting for the screenplay to
catch up weird this movie did devolve
into a Criminal Minds episode which I
somewhat predicted earlier also huh I
guess me is into the same was her
brother I could have been Christian Grey
I'm smarter I've got more balls villain
ex posits to the main character and
therefore the audience before committing
villainy cliche don't tell anybody or
you'll get his little sister back in
pieces
man Jack graduated from publishing
management to casual human butchery in
like a matter of weeks movie will push
Anna around like a chess piece during
the finale all due to some death sibling
in-law love exploitation but still
sister Christian hasn't met these movies
until now right at the end of the last
movie Jesus bring half ass in Christ
before we start this madcap rush to the
end of the movie let's pause for five
full seconds to watch Anna put her hair
up I didn't need to grab some bags five
million in cash takes up a lot of space
really actually it depends on the
denomination of the bills if they're all
hundies you got nothing to fear you can
help me in the library please this is
great what you're saying these security
personnel could be outsmarted really
don't know god damn it she's trying to
have none of her loved ones died Jesus
Christ expand your horizons on what
counts is worthy of your attention I
hate you wait for me they're only 15
minutes please don't and Anna's giving
Jack a tremendous amount of respect in
this situation sure he's got me a
captive in his threatening her but how
would he know if she told Christian
about it not like the motherfucker
special-ops or something he was a
goddamn editor sir your sister Mia is
missing we can't find her and those are
definitely two different things that I
had to say separately you know how I
love dramatic timing sir
detective the same day that high gets
out my sister goes missing and my wife
takes five million dollars out of our
account you think that's a coincidence
actually I think it's lazy writing but
potatoe extortion also at least 87
percent of the last 10 minutes of this
movie has been people talking on fucking
cell phones get in the back Liz will be
way overestimates my interest ability to
keep up with what's like the 560 third
character in this franchise
damn I was so close to basic competence
I see Jack stocked up on his psychotic
stalker I make up for this confrontation
Maybelline is constantly innovating and
she's not dead not yes let's talk about
Jack's plan he was apparently
responsible for Christians helicopter
crash in the last movie but Christian
survived after that didn't work he broke
into the office stole some files and
exploded the server room but the
security camera was able to identify him
leading to him becoming a criminal
suspect then he broke into the greys
apartment to kidnap Anna despite knowing
there was a security detail assigned to
her which led to his arrest and now
after kidnapping Mia to prompt Anna to
actually bring the ransom money he
starts beating her ass instead of
running he shooting himself in the foot
so much that Anna doesn't even need to
use her gun I know you just woke up from
the movie coma but is it too early to
start talking about using the butt plugs
again why did you tell me what was going
on Jack threatened me
no he threatened me oh damn I think the
movie fast forwarded itself just to
watch the sex scenes you were given a
life with advantages look what you made
of it you know like your sex dungeon
Christian it seems that they've found
where your birth mother is buried why
the fuck was this information included
in the packet about Jack what does this
do for the movie anyway God please just
let the series die 61 seconds of
franchise flashbacks and none of them
are about boning mid-credits scene is so
useless it makes Captain America's
appearance at the end of spider-man
homecoming look like a central viewing
no you're not putting those in my but
they don't go in your but whatever you
say this is great how about I just go
eat some hay I can make things out of
clay and lay by the bay I just made with
the motion I could have been Christian
Grey excuse me please be quiet I suggest
you stop making eyes at my husband and
keep your hands to yourself can't keep
my hands to myself
[Music]
tiller right here over the bridge to
South Park I'm going down to South I'm
gonna have myself a time